but then how are you a good wife if you
leave
well if you don't have the reason to
stay you you have to leave I would say
what makes a good wife is being the type
of woman that can motivate and inspire a
man to be the best version of himself so
I think women need attention like like
men need
s but women are never expected to close
off their social media
I want to be a wife yes and if so
what makes a good wife so starting here
and I go wow
what makes a good wife
um I think companionship like definitely
friendship I think that's a big thing in
a marriage
um I wouldn't know that because I'm not
married but you know something I want is
to be literally my partner's best friend
um
you think men want a best friend yeah
100 100 okay yeah
yeah even me it's not all the time but
okay okay anything else
um
just just to be there just show up okay
yeah women don't have to do anything but
be a best friend and show up to be a
wife okay not just that okay
so I'm just going to go off of what you
say so
um
just I I don't know okay I just um
because we live in this in a society
like this it doesn't like cooking and
like traditional things I've I don't
even feel like it should be like you
know should be half yeah divided
definitely so I don't think it's like a
compulsory thing do you think all the
like fixing stuff around the house
should be divided half half fixing the
car
um
so the dates be half half I'm just I'm
just you know we're gonna this is the
afternoon right yeah and that would be a
good wife yeah I'll split the chores
with you I'll be your best friend yes
okay okay go ahead
um what do I think a wife do you want to
be a wife and What Makes a Good Wife
yeah I do want to be a wife
um I would say what makes a good wife is
being the type of woman that can
motivate and inspire a man to be the
best version of himself because I feel
like with a good woman by his side
supporting him a man can do incredible
things and I feel like some men are
lacking
that in their lives like they're like
they don't have that woman that's there
guiding them and like being supportive
and motivating him and lifting him up
um so how would a girl do that
just inspiring a man to be the best
version of himself like
um how
so like if I said I wanna I wanna I
wanna be a good wife and I'm coming to
you how can I inspire
well I feel like you you have to be a
good woman yourself first like you have
to be
like you have to be basically having
your own things like you have to be
independent you have to be like cultured
worldly intellectual
um you have to have things that also
Inspire the man and I feel like when you
have those things as a woman you can
bring those into the relationship and
the man sees you he sees your worth he
sees your value and he's like I've got
to step my game up like I've got to be
the best man for her
um because you inspire him to be like
that you know and where did you learn
this is this from your parents or did
you learn it somewhere else
yeah I did I think my mum really helped
my dad become the best version of
himself she helped him on the straight
road she made him cut out a lot of toxic
how did she do that
um because of her morals like she had
real strong morals he saw her value he
saw what type of woman she was and he
wanted to lock it down straight away he
was like this is like a real good woman
like she's you know there for me she's
supporting me she's trying to help me
build she wants to help me build this
Empire so I've got to get my act
together so yeah I did watch my mom and
dad like that because my question is
more you said independent and I just
when in history have Independent Women
have men wanted Independent Women
like what men have always wanted women
yeah that relied on them when I'm when
I'm in sorry I just want to rephrase
that when I meant independent I meant as
in like she is able to stand on her own
two feet like she doesn't need him she's
not constantly needing him she doesn't
give off that like needy clinginess like
she can do things around on her own but
she would rather let the man do things
for her if that makes sense but if he
wasn't around and God forbid something
happened then she'd be able to stand on
her own two feet because I feel like men
do want that they don't want to know
that you like
constantly like need them emotionally
mentally everything I've never heard a
guy say that he doesn't want a girl that
needs him but there's so many guys that
get turned off by it you know if they
don't like you if like usually it's like
a girl that's like a little bit too ugly
for him like typically like she's a
little bit below his typical league and
like that's why she's annoying to him
because she's not in his like
League
yeah like have you ever said a guy that
was into a girl that's like oh she's too
needy she wants me too much
I mean I have had men say that but yeah
I guess may be bad with the wrong woman
I guess I don't know okay okay what do
you think well I think the woman needs
to look after the house I think she have
to
um be there for him like to support him
and I think the friendship is important
as well
um I don't know the respect as well
okay so you think she should take care
of the house she's respectful to him
yeah friendship I think that's important
okay they can be friends they can do
things together they can even house
things they can do together okay all
right go ahead
it's a weird one for me well do you want
to be a wife and did you say do you want
you want to do it well it's a tricky one
for me because I actually was a wife
okay uh but now I'm single so yeah I
want to be a wife okay all right go
ahead sorry I just love love I love love
I love
um
I kind of like the idea of
being a wife equaling things if that
makes sense like paying for dates
supporting our family supporting our
house when it comes to building stuff I
don't think so I like it though
um so you'll have the money
the 50 50 on the money but again it I I
understand it comes to some extents
obviously we get pregnant we
um leave obviously because we are with
child
um
so I like the way you said that yes
what's your question actually what makes
a good what makes a good wife makes a
good wife morals morals and I think
would you include like loyalty in that
absolutely okay so you'd say a woman's a
bad wife if she leaves no right no I I
did not disagree yeah but then how are
you a good wife if you leave
well if you don't have the reason to
stay you you have to leave you know
commitment vows
I think like
um to be married and to have a family
like I think that's beautiful and it can
be beautiful
um it's
it's comic it's a commitment and it's
hard
I feel like a lot of people
don't like to go through the hardship
but the hardship makes you stronger but
the good wives go through the hardship
and the bad wives leave no
I was asking her but you can
um I'm gonna think about that one I'm
just I'm trying to I'm trying to
understand I don't know like this I just
think if you're good at something you
get it done yeah I feel like
um
it goes down to like being a team
you know and like working on things
together and progressing the
relationship together you know so if
someone's slacking
fair enough and if it is a long period
of time or it does affect the
relationship or you know
then you gotta cut it basically all
right all right what do you think makes
it good actually I'm gonna do the girls
first okay so what do you think do you
want to be a wife and what makes a good
wife I'm gonna be controversial in
saying not really don't want to be away
no I only want I would only get married
if it was something that the other
person felt really strongly about but to
me
if you're in a relationship and you're
that committed to that person what what
is a marriage going to do like what is
that commitment saying to other people
exactly and if I'm not committed to
someone that I feel like I should be
married to them
unless I believe in the religious
beliefs behind it
I just don't see it as being a bigger
progression in the commitment I should
be committed regardless okay and there
shouldn't be something on paper to state
that I have to be that way it should
just be a mutual agreement that you're
both just and committed and committed
and nothing's going to change about that
so personally it's not something that I
like
will ever try to force on someone or
something that I really want but if they
feel very passionately about it and I
feel like it's the right time I'm okay
with that okay and it's just something I
don't feel like what do you what do you
think makes a good wife
so
in all honesty I think just being there
as the other half
like I know you discussed about it and
you played them basically yeah I know
you discussed it as being like you know
a woman has a role in a relationship but
I'm actually bisexual so to me it could
work either way okay and to me I feel
like 50 50 is where that kind of stuff
needs to fall into place 50 50 on
everything because not necessarily it
give and take okay so if you have to
look at the person's attributes what
they give to a relationship and break it
down that way I don't think it's a one
size fits all I don't think everyone can
say right you're gonna do this you're
going to do that because you're the man
the man can be he could be really
bad at it he could be amazing at it yeah
perfect let them work to their strengths
I think that's what works in a
relationship when you let the other
person working together yeah sure but I
think there are some things that
regardless whether you're traditional or
not there are some things that
naturally a man might be better a woman
might be better at or very different
biologically so there's always going to
be things that a man's going to be
slightly better at than a woman unless
they're you're an anomaly and you're
going to be 10 times stronger than the
man that's unlikely so I I think yeah
give or take it I think everything has
to be looked at retrospectively and it
has to be broken down about each
person's attributes and what they can
give to the situation so what do you
think makes a woman a good wife
like what's just specific because this
is just a bit broad so I'm just trying
to kind of Reign it in you know fair
enough
um so being able to provide in a sense
that you can about provide emotionally
whether you can provide financially is
irrelevant if the other person can
provide financially perfect you then
need to make up for the other gaps so as
a wife you might need to be able to be
able to look after children or be able
to look after man or the man be able to
look after you and you'll be receiving
to that because I think a lot of women
nowadays look at a relationship and
think the man should have to meet the
first of everything do everything but
that makes a lot of men very not a lot
of men but nowadays it makes them quite
intimidated and then they get nervous
and then they think oh what if I can't
do that you have to be receptive to what
they want to do if they want to buy food
for you let them if they want to take
you out an idea and they want to pay for
everything I'm asking what does she have
to do she has to be receptive yeah
receive what else does she have to do
um
again see because it's something that I
personally you don't don't yeah I don't
know it's something that I wouldn't
really have values on so I don't really
think what I'm going to say is going to
give you much much information to be
honest okay no worries all right so
question do you want to be a husband do
I want to be a husband
um I am not enthusiastic about it with
the way that marriage is with with laws
and just with the way the culture is in
general
um and I've been that way for a long
time I mean like as it was my parents
divorced when I was a kid so I never
really had a great argument uh you know
a great example for sort of marriage and
and that kind of thing anyway and
obviously as time's gone on you know
we've seen what's happened in terms of
the way that Society is here in the USA
and Canada and Australia you know those
Western countries it's it's it's not a
good deal to be honest it's never been
something that I've been particularly
keen on I've become less keen on the
idea as I've gone on really now in a
sense I agree with what you said because
I think long-term relationship fine
commitment fine do you want to put a
ring on it probably not you know it
would have to be a very good reason for
doing it or do it somewhere else like do
it over in um maybe one of the you know
Latin American countries or something
like that okay and um out of what did
you hear who did I marry out no no
okay
what did you hear you here today was
there anything you heard that you
thought yes that would make a good way
I think a lot of the women were
a bit light on specifics to to be honest
you know there's a lot of stuff yeah
support and blah blah blah but there's
there's a lot there wasn't much
specifics in terms of what what is the
woman actually going to bring to the
table so
um I would say that but I mean I I think
really you want somebody who is
gonna support you who's gonna be easy to
be around you know
um and I think marriage works pretty
well back in the day when things were
more traditional to be honest and I
think now we've come away from that it
just doesn't work as well you know and
um we're seeing that and you know as we
know the majority of divorces are caused
by women you know 70 of divorces are
initiated by women so it's women who are
women which is why modern women are
shitty wives exactly exactly but yeah
but that's another reason another reason
I'm not keen to go into it because for
guys it's a bit of a bad deal because
you know that women are very keen to get
married you know women will try to push
the agenda of like oh you know where are
we are we going to get engaged are we
moving in together we're gonna get
married
but then they get fed up you know 10 15
10 15 years like down the line and they
initiate a divorce and then the guy's
screwed so but why is she fed up why is
she fed up I well I think I mean there's
going to be many different reasons for
that and we could go into lots of
different examples but I think a lot of
it is that they lose the this you know
the butterflies go because and it's
inevitably gonna go over a longer period
of time because we all know you have
that honeymoon period and then you know
it gets it's always yeah yeah then it
gets it gets a bit boring and the
problem with that is that if you're then
putting that into a legal contract where
one of the parties could just say I'll
sod that and walk out that's a Dangerous
Ground I think no like I've got I don't
know like I've just got a thought
like obviously you said woman leave in a
marriage of course which I understand
but
I'm 21 like I know I'm still young but I
feel like there's a specific time period
to have kids
and to marry and settle down and I feel
like I don't know like this little
pressure because if I put myself in a
guy's
perspective of shoes like I'm not
burying a child and that changes your
body it does it changes yeah we are of
course we have the biological clock
where we're all aware of it
yeah it's harder for us I think that's
why probably why we want to lock it down
oh yeah yeah yeah sure sure yeah yeah
and like with women leaving again this
is such a broad subject so I'm not I'm
not on about just cheating by the way
yeah
um but yeah one off it's like
I get and understand why men do like
cheese yeah and leave and go for younger
women well what I love it's actually not
such a broad thing though well men don't
typically leave for younger women they
don't even leave no they're just gonna
cheat on his face
but women cheat in their own way I mean
I think personally I think that sex is
to to men as attention is to women
so I think women need attention like
like men need sex but women are never
expected to close off their social media
yeah yeah but men are expected to stop
having sex with other girls how's that
fair but women can post ass pics on
their Instagram
nobody can touch it well nobody can
touch it yeah it's like advertising I
mean I was even looking at okay
imagine okay Selena by the way
okay I don't know about the Selena
Haley whatever no I don't I don't care
what I was looking at was her Instagram
I was like she's married to a world
famous pop star yeah and I know she's a
model right but he's a world at that
point but he's he's got groupies yeah
and he's also very religious apparently
I don't know what's going on so it's
like you're married to a world famous
pop star and you still got
look at look at the booty one look at it
yeah look at that yeah okay and the
funny thing is he comments on it as well
so it's bizarre as long as he's okay
with it he's like oh my God yeah but
would she be okay with it if we
commenting under somebody else's post no
would she be okay I think it works one
of two ways like you can't you can't
take one side just because one's a
female and then you're not fat the other
side like true pick your own battles all
all the same but don't don't come at the
man for cheating if she's gonna put it
out there as if she's gonna cheat as
well well interesting though you say
that well I just think of it as like
like mating strategies like women want
to get attention from high status men
that's Instagram
men want to screw as many people as
possible so like how many I don't know
anyone that got married and closed their
Instagram I don't know anyone that did
it like my age anyway actually I told
you right so yeah so I'm saying modern
women are shitty ones why would she
close your Instagram I don't understand
that because
[Laughter]
[Music]
You could argue Justin Bieber's job is
to screw groupies on tour
the model what it's different he's not
he's not a model right so I do get what
you're saying it's the world famous pop
star
the world famous pop stars to do they
screw groupies on the tour
bro's oldest time that's better I mean
yeah it is that's Chris Brown do on
snake come on
yeah yeah and you know you can just tell
she would have none of that if he was
doing that yeah but it's like we're a
society where men aren't told they can
do that they're controlling if they tell
a girl to close her Instagram but women
immediately want you to stop sleeping
with other girls and you can tell like I
know so many people in relationships
who've told people unfollow her stop
liking her photos I know get rid of her
if you do it to a man or if you're in a
relationship with another girl and you
tell her not to do that you're the bad
person well you've got to be careful it
goes one or two like you have to look
see I think that's a standard respect
thing
but if you're gonna do it one way and
not accept it backwards yeah but there's
different hold on hold on I feel this
might be controversial but I feel like
there are different
um there are different reasons and
there's people with different
circumstances for example if there was
if you was dating someone and she was
for example like a content creator or
something and she had she was in you
know Instagram engagement groups so if
she was an engagement group in an
engagement group There are rules you
have to like everyone's photo to help
each other with the algorithm right so
would you then turn around to your
girlfriend and say to her I don't want
you liking pictures of other guys the
standard person isn't honestly like I'm
not famous
but would a good wife argue with him
when he asks that and say well but my
Instagram grouper would she just say
okay whatever you say honey yeah in a
really traditional setup that she she
would give it up probably yeah you know
she would if she's making six figures
well regardless of no Rick and William
regardless of if he's making six figures
she should be like listen you know we're
married now that is the I made this
commitment in the in the eyes of the
Lord exactly and in the eyes of God so
that's more important to me than having
Instagram account you know that's what
she would have said in the back of the
day okay so I have a question why does
he have to be making six figures to have
to be listened to and do you have the
same energy if a woman's Med does she is
she if she's average looking does she
not is she not able to ask for loyalty
um that's a good question but you know
she's average looking so why why does
she get to ask for that yeah
um
I don't know I I don't really know how
to answer that because I just feel like
women do definitely look at Men's
financial status and we can sit here and
argue about that all the time but at the
end of the day there is survival and
women would always try to go with
someone above her level or at least on
her level she will never go low so you
said six figures
that's 10 a month no I know I was just
trying to be funny there but like
um no but I'm just saying like
realistically she will always go above
or on the same level so she's never
gonna go low so financial status does
get looked at and that is actually how
men earn respect from women I feel like
it's one of the ways that if you want to
earn respect from a woman you need to do
that you need to be a monkey Bank yeah
no bro no brokies
how much does he have to make what about
an average guy
um I don't know I don't know what the
average salary here is what is it like
40 30. depends on your age so like 25
year olds gonna be earning like 35
000. all right which in London isn't
going to be very much in the standards
of learning six figures
and then it's on it's unfair to expect
that off someone
you've got the average you've got the
average UK wage though which is probably
like it's going to be weighted higher in
London yeah yeah because you've got
extremities you've got you know if
you're looking at the mean it's going to
be taking both these I mean does the man
expect us to be top 10 20 30 of beauty
no
but why should they not if we're
expecting them to be in the highway I
think they do want that yeah they might
want it but they're not they're not
going to hold out for it because most
guys are quite thirsty do you know what
I mean we'll talk about this the other
obviously the other night most guys are
quite thirsty
they're gonna take what they could get
you know oh oh yeah I mean that's a good
point it's a good point have you heard
the husband's store analogy no oh
there's like I hope I say this right
there's like a husband store analogy in
the manosphere okay and basically every
every store or every floor
is a different set of husbands okay and
you go up before
um then the only rules you can't go back
down so there's five floors total and
you you can go up but you can't go down
so the first floor is guys that love
kids
yeah and our and our loyal to you oh
that's sweet and so the women go to the
first floor so they go to the first
floor and they say you know what I want
more I wanna I wanna go up so they go to
the second floor and then they fight
they should do one no no no it gets
better it gets better so these guys love
kids they're loyal and they're hot oh
they're sexy yeah
next floor okay then they get just
curious yeah yeah so they go what's
what's next curiosity and they say they
say they say okay the next floor these
guys are hot they make 70 000 a year
they love kids and they're loyal
but she's on the third floor and she's
like well what's what's happening what's
on the next floor and so back at it then
she goes next they make six figures
love kids loyal
everything but she wants to go to the
fifth floor and on the fifth is this
to us all the husbands are sold out
I love the dogs because die alone
I mean so so that to make it fair they
did a wife score or a wife store right
so on the first floor there's women good
sex loyal
Texas and they never found out was it
what was on the second floor
yeah good enough
I think modern day woman no offense and
I know I'm a woman but are super like
materialistic I don't agree with that I
really I I I love I love most of my
friends but I know if they were given
the opportunity to go with someone who
aren't like over a million they will
take it they would take it and they'll
cheat on the person that they love and
they feel committed to and that's such
an issue well they cheat for money
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
but it's been normalized it's seen as
normal now to cheat and it seemed as
normal to like be like oh yeah but he's
better
why why not just fight three finally
better because he have money exactly why
is it why is that important
exactly and that's why guys shouldn't
get married because that's the dynamic
that's the dynamic but you're as a guy
you're entering into a contract with
somebody when that is the dynamic that's
going on in society and that's very
problematic because you're you're
basically marrying into it's like it's
like buying a house that it's got loads
of faults with the house and you're
going to have loads of money to pay
further down the line it's like you're
buying you're getting into a contract
with somebody who is being influenced by
the society that's basically saying to
you there's always going to be better
there's always your and not only is that
always going to be better but you
deserve better you know you go girl you
go on to the next dude
like a mobile phone contract
at any time
like why is that worth it my Grandma had
13 kids for a fireman and she submitted
to him and that's that's the thing like
modern that's a good job but that's
beautiful that is what it should be it
was an average salary back then and so
I'm I'm just saying like you know what
is this generation this generation is
just getting worse but but money
shouldn't be the end and it is what it
is
if you feel that emotionally attached to
someone like if you're someone like me
that doesn't want to particularly get
married if you feel that emotionally
attached that you're willing to get
married you should not just up and leave
because someone else has more money or
someone else maybe is more attractive
like it should be all taken as I've
committed to this person for a reason
there was something there unless there's
something a lot deeper going on like
abuse or or something that is a lot
deeper and it's a lot more complex if
it's something as simple as that person
earns more I'm gonna go with them
so do you think that the woman so would
you say you think that the woman should
stick it out basically even if there is
like a period of suffering not
necessarily stick out but don't if it
works say this man that she's with is
like literally not hardly making any
money they are really struggling like
times are really tough for her and do
you think that she should just stay and
stick it out or do you think she should
want better for herself
all right
um
I take you for my lawfully wedded
husband
all right for better for worse for
richer or for poorer and sickness and
health till death do us part if you
believe in leaving the second there's a
rough patch you might get married
chip at that point oh that boy but
that's all Boomer stuff that Bible
but the whole point is like if if you
believe in divorce then why get married
there's no point just be in a
relationship because you're not a wife I
mean you you getting married and then
you think oh I'm gonna divorce one day
that's why they're on some prenups
though because it's like well I don't
think anyone wants to get divorced when
they get married they think it's forever
but I think things happen yeah and you
have to be realistic that but that's I'm
not saying that maybe you marry someone
and in the beginning it's all good and
then suddenly when you get married he
might lose his money and then leave him
no I don't agree with that but I feel
like yeah I feel like you should still
stay with that person but if there's no
progress there's no sign of him you know
working hard or trying we're trying to
get back to that level that he was at
before you know it's time to call it
quick this is what that's one more time
one more time
Better or For Worse for richer for
poorer yeah and sickness and in health
until death do us anyways that's it this
is what Massey the the author of the
rational male who talks a lot about this
kind of these kind of intergender
Dynamics he talks about the burden of
performance on men and that's exactly
what you're talking about then there's
always this there's this burden of
performance on men it's like okay well
he could have a rough patch but if he
doesn't shape up after two years you
know she's gonna be like thinking well
hang on what's going on which is
all right I understand why you would say
that but that is contrary to what Pearl
right now because the agreement is For
Better or Worse for sicker and poorer
because it could be he's got some
underlying issue like he's got maybe
some underlying like like depression or
something like that he's trying to deal
with some trouble and he's not working
he's not pushing himself to the degree
because of that but you know the the
woman who disregards that could just say
well sorry you know I'm gonna go for
Steve over here because he's making six
figures so I have a question so the same
way you believe that
um if he's not making more money or
working or whatever you should live
should he leave her if she gets fat
[Laughter]
I'm just asking yes
um
I think he's he's allowed to to bring it
up yeah for sure
we're gonna give her some chance you
know to get in the gym she got like
three months six months oh well no
because she's not gonna leave him like
if the woman is like in that situation
she's not we're not saying the woman's
just gonna go right oh you're not
working for three months off I go like
it's not gonna happen like that she's
obviously gonna stick it out she's gonna
try and help especially if you've got
kids it's different like she may not be
able to go back to work they may have to
find alternative ways of surviving I
don't know it's very difficult but she's
not going to leave straight away it's
it's you know over a few years three
four years maybe I don't know
um and in the same yeah same energy for
for the man as well if the woman's
completely let herself go and you know
she's not taking care of herself forget
the man it's not even good for you as a
woman forget him like it's about you
like you want to be able to look
yourself in the mirror and feel
confident and happy and you know
comfortable in your skin so go out and
do something about it so I yeah but he
have to make sure you you get like some
compliments about it you know so it can
make you feel better but are you going
to give him the same compliments if he
has no job oh yeah yeah you know what I
mean yeah
I have a question do you Journey do you
genuinely think most women nicely ask or
do you think most women nag let's just
window
okay baby I'm so happy you didn't do
that thing I asked you to do last
weekend very happy
the woman condition yeah
it would be a way but the female
condition is very different to a man as
well like we we do like to
no offense but picket things yeah
whereas a man will be very much more
upfront about it and if they have an
issue or something most of the time most
the time not all men I I know not all
men are quite as straightforward as that
but most men will just say it as it is
whereas woman will sugarcoat things